now to haiti where police say they have
arrested one of the masterminds behind
the assassination of president
giovannelle moyes
moise was gunned down at his home last
week
officials suspect that the arrested man
wanted to oust the president
and take over himself as head of the
country
police have identified the suspect as a
haitian national
other reports say that the man was a u.s
resident
with a private security company to
recruit some of the people
who committed this act
police had already arrested a number of
haitians and colombians
suspected of being part of the
assassination unit responsible for last
week's killing
of president johannes moyes but many
questions remain
when did they leave colombia who paid
for their plane tickets
with whom were they in communication
what is the source of their funding
who paid them
a team of us agents arrived in haiti on
sunday
meeting with central members of haiti's
government
i thank the international community
especially the united states
who offered their assistance in the
investigation
church leaders on sunday asked for calm
and
told people to remain strong
the assassination of the president has
created a power vacuum
and so confusion over who is haiti's
legitimate leader
politicians are fighting amongst
themselves each one is claiming power
the country's had a leadership problem
since 1804
our leaders never think of the people
they always just use the people
should defend their own interests
haiti was in bad shape before the
president's assassination
it's plagued by gang violence and
corruption
and haitians live in crushing poverty
quiet streets in the capital porto
prance on sunday
a contrast to the ongoing political
turmoil
and for more let's bring in ann roshone
a journalist who is based
in haiti and thank you so much for
joining us what else do we know about
the latest
about this suspect who was arrested over
moyes's assassination
the person that was arrested was a
so-called fixer who was living in
florida
and he was making several videos
opposition videos against the
javanese which is nothing special per se
because many people did that he was
arrested yesterday
and he was pointed out by the chief of
police that
he might be the stringer for this
assassination or the one that wanted to
put himself in power afterwards
and what they say is that he found
that the colombians immediately after
the assassination i phoned this man
immediately afterwards and that this man
phoned then
the two masterminds without saying
whether they know who the masterminds
were
or whether these masterminds would be
arrested very soon
okay i mean still a lot of details to be
fleshed out there but
at least some initial indications now we
have haitian officials asking
the united states for help investigating
the case restoring order getting some
answers here
what should we make of that
well i the amer the united states of
america has sent
several times in the past fbi
agents in order to try to understand
what happens in high-profile killings
and
it is to be seen what kind of personnel
they are going to deploy on the ground
and how much they are going to invest in
this investigation however i
do believe they will invest heavily in
order to understand what really happened
how are haitians on the ground in the
meantime reacting to all of this chaos
well most of the people are trying to
get groceries
and stuff in the humble people are
trying to make a little money
because there is a lot of threats for
this week that there will be
demonstrations uprising the so-called
barbecue gang leader his name is
barbecue because he is burning his
victims
it was declaring war against the
bourgeoisie of haiti
and that he is going to take vengeance
for the assassination of jovenel muis
without of course for not forgetting
that
only last week he was saying george
nelly movies has to go
so it is a big mess and everybody is
trying to get
ready for this week as nobody knows
what's really going to happen
journalists and roshone thank you so
much
thank you